i don't know what future social networks
are exactly i do know on a shallow level
it does feel good when somebody clicks
like on something
i think that is more of a drug than an
actual deep
long-lasting fulfilling happiness but
perhaps there is a way to make a social
network that does lead to
long-lasting happiness that's somehow
detached from the physical
meat space i don't know but it feels
like you want to give that a chance
do you think when people are liking
things on social media
do you think there's just a group of
people an overwhelming majority of
people that are going to like whatever
you put out there they're clicking like
and then there's another section of
people that just constantly scroll and
like
scroll and like and scroll and like like
do you think
when you get a like on content you put
out that that like perhaps came from
someone who normally doesn't like your
content but like you've just
changed their mind on something or you
you've turned them around on it
yeah i tend to think that when i get
likes on social media those are just the
people that like all my no matter
what i say
like they probably don't even read it
like i could you know put the most
preposterous thing up there
and you're still gonna get a handful of
the same exact likes that's interesting
but i i tend to
the way i see likes you're kind of you
said multiple things
i think in one sense you see social
media as like a battleground of ideas
and like is it kind of indicate like the
best possible like is an indicator of
like
of the of you winning over somebody on
an idea and they really appreciate the
idea that's the best possible life
to me a like is just two strangers
smiling at each other
like like a moment of like like
i got you bro yeah i got you bro yeah
yeah like
fist bump like yeah we're in this
thing together
this whole thing doesn't make any sense
but we're in this together and
i yeah it's possible for likes to be
that i i don't
think the actual clicking of a like i
think social media at its best
might be that where it's like i got you
bro
and it's a large scale as opposed to
kind of
uh this weird uh like
crazy pool of dopamine where everyone's
just obsessed with this likes and likes
and
and then the division drives like more
of this like weird anxious engagement
i think that's just the dark version of
it in the early days of social media
i think you called it uh a battleground
of ideas but i think social media is
nothing but a battleground of fragile
egos
well but humans are fragile egos i mean
maybe but i think the people i think
particularly on social media
they're the most fragile like
would you be doing all the things you're
doing what would you be doing if you
weren't
um if you weren't podcasting
and posting the things you do on social
media
what would you be doing you'd probably
be much the same guy
right but i think that on social media
the fragile ego people
what you see on social media is not what
they'd be doing without social media
does that make any sense like you're
you're probably your mission is probably
somewhat congruent
in your path you're just utilizing
social media but i think a lot of people
social media has changed their path and
and now they're doing something
totally foreign to them
and they're only able to do it maybe
because of social media i think you're
focusing on a particular
moment in time of people in their
less great moments like in their less
great version of themselves i think
you're just focusing on the masses
struggling to uh
to become the best version of themselves
and then you yeah sure
for stretches of time whether it's days
weeks and months you could be a shitty
person on the internet
i think you're
focusing on that and unfortunately
social media platforms
emphasize they love it when you're like
that when you're not doing great in your
own
in your own life because it increases
anxiety increased
engagement makes you more susceptible to
an argument
and then really get pulled into like
conspiracy theories all that kind of
stuff
but the other side works too i think
there's also the people who are on
social media like
fronting like they're these positive
figures and like you know
going to the gym like whatever it is the
positivity that they spew out but in
real life they're the most negative
you've ever met in your life and
they're just so full of crap
and it's just you people playing to an
audience it's like you like you said
like they
it's like a politician sometimes like a
politician wakes up one day and they
decide
who's the group i can pander to the best
to get the most likes equals votes yeah
and it's the same thing on social media
people wake up and whether it's
conscious or not
what's the group i can pander to the
best to get the most likes is it the
positivity motivated crowd
is it the woe was me crowd like what is
it who's gonna give me the most likes
that's what i'll do uh i i don't know
how to argue against that i
guess it's it's uh it rings true
what you're saying but i just kind of
refuse to believe it
i guess i'm pandering to the optimistic
crowd
like i met with my marketing team and i
just feel that
uh uh love has the uh the best
what do you call it no i don't know
there's a lot of people that accuse me
of being like
exactly that which is like why are you
always being positive it's like
well because i i'd like to be that
yeah but i don't i wouldn't consider you
someone who panders
no but you know it i guess what i'm
saying is like
uh it's easy to say that everyone is
pandering
but like maybe they're just trying
i i do believe that social media
platforms could encourage people when
they're trying to be the best version of
themselves whatever that is
it could be like conor mcgregor talking
it could be just being positive
it could be actually creating cool
things in this world um
putting out instructional videos for jiu
jitsu or like inspiring students to
competition all
i don't know all those kinds of things
educational content
i i think that people are trying like i
i tend to believe that people
want to be good like
like they want to be successful whatever
that definition of success is and
they're kind of struggling to do that
and they're just
awkward at it at first and like it's
easy to focus on the awkwardness
and the the stumbling around as people
have that and they start on
each other like
it's easy to kind of focus in on that
but i think that's just like
people you know white belts there's more
white belts in the world than there are
black belts but you gotta give them a
chance to kind of grow
i think on social media if you put your
stuff out there whatever your stuff is
your content your views or whatever
you let the chips fall where they may
like that's a different thing than being
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna tweak what i normally might
say and put it up this way because i
want
these people to like it and in terms
i also think i have a different
viewpoint than you do on people wanting
to be successful
i actually don't think that many people
want to be successful
i think people want to have the
appearance of wanting to be successful
but to be successful takes a shitload of
work and most people don't want to put
that work in
so they craft this persona of a person
who's trying really hard but just can't
catch the break or
uh you know these with
getting back on my grind
you've never been on a grind you've been
on the couch i so disagree with you i i
get it
i get it you you that's your foil you
enjoyed that guy in the couch with the
cheetos
that's you that's that's your motivation
but just own it be like
don't be like back on the ground back on
the couch yeah
well you you're like david goggins who's
like talking to the one guy with
the eating cheetos and
in in so doing inspires millions to like
to actually pursue their success i get
it but i just think that most people
really do want to be
successful and are like are trying to
work hard and they keep failing
uh so i mean but why is it why does it
continue i'm sorry to interrupt you
but like let's take a person who's
overweight yeah do you not think that
person wants to be skinny of course they
want to be skinny
they just don't want it enough to put
the pizza or the pie down and go to the
gym
they want it but they want it to be easy
of course they want to be skinny
well of course he wants it to be easy
right and of course people people want
to be successful
but do they want it enough to do the
work i don't think they do
i think the easy thing to do is to to
create a uh
an outward facing persona of the person
who really wants it
and you get the same reward from a lot
of people
as the person who actually is successful
very few people differentiate from the
person who's found success
and and the person who's showing you how
they're trying to get success on social
media
people see that as the same i see i see
you're going after the
marketing dollar that represents the uh
the people that want to work hard
yeah i like it
you